sentidos
[Música]
cuando todos
l bien le entrará alguien en una
discoteca por su forma de vestir o por
su estado de ebriedad no hay ninguna
novedad pero en corea del sur es posible
que a uno no lo dejen entrar por su
nacionalidad en tick tock los
expatriados se han grabado siendo objeto
de lo que consideran discriminación
cinco extranjeros que viven en corea del
sur le confirmaron a nuestra redacción
haber vivido esta situación entre ellos
está a kristen kilos un estudiante
afroamericana que vive en seúl según
ella esta discriminación afecta sobre
todo a las personas negras pero también
a las personas de piel oscura del sur de
asia y del norte de áfrica
hace dos años fui a una discoteca
bastante popular en galán el portero
miro a mi amigo y le dijo hay personas
en tu grupo que no pueden entrar
después me miró de arriba abajo y me
dijo dress com
es bastante común que te digan hay
demasiados extranjeros o no puedes
entrar y sin embargo veas que a los
blancos los dejan entrar y salir
también hay discotecas en las que tienes
que mostrar tu pasaporte para que
revisen si tienes la edad para beber si
ven que eres norafricano por ejemplo
marroquí no te dejan entrar
según kristen que los lugares que
rechazan a las personas por su origen
siguen siendo una minoría pero es
difícil denunciarlos en corea del sur
las personas que no aportan pruebas
suficientes en está una posición pública
pueden enfrentarse a penas de prisión
así que christina decidió crear una
lista colaborativa de lugares a los que
los extranjeros pueden ir sin temor a
ser discriminados
muchas veces son los expatriados negros
y de piel oscura los que tienen que
adivinar si van a ser discriminados
music y mejor varices
y creamos esta lista para facilitarle la
vida a la gente y también porque ya hay
suficiente sufrimiento infligido a
nuestra comunidad ya muchas otras es una
forma de decir que nos quedamos aquí y
que no vamos a ninguna parte nuestra
cultura tiene derecho a existir aquí la
discriminación y el racismo no son
aceptables
misma
el derrumbe de la torre metropol el
pasado 23 de mayo un edificio de 10
pisos en el suroeste de irán indigno a
los iraníes dos semanas después de la
tragedia los equipos de rescate de la
ciudad de abadán siguen sacando
cadáveres de entre los escombros se han
encontrado al menos 40 personas muertas
muchos residentes acusan a la corrupción
política y económica de la construcción
mal hecha pero también a la lentitud de
las operaciones de rescate hablamos con
una joven iraní que acudió al lugar poco
después del derrumbe para ayudar desea
permanecer en el anonimato por su propia
seguridad
la mayor parte del esfuerzo para
rescatar a las víctimas ha recaído en
los hombros de la población local y los
voluntarios los bomberos y la media luna
roja parecen desbordados nadie sabe lo
que ocurre en el lugar
yolanda de la misma tal
y toda forma de andar no me agrada nada
los voluntarios intentaron desenterrar a
los sobrevivientes y los cuerpos ellos
mismos para hacerlo trajeron
herramientas improvisadas que pensaron
que serían útiles serruchos palas e
incluso ollas para remover la grava
los equipos de rescate están trabajando
con grandes máquinas para despejar las
urnas pero estos son una pequeña parte
del trabajo para encontrar los cuerpos
hay que excavar a mano y arrastrarse
bajo toneladas de grava y cemento lo
peor es que la organización nacional de
gestión de crisis ordenó el despliegue
de muchos policías antidisturbios en la
ciudad desde otras regiones
la ira aumentó cuando los periodistas
locales revelaron que el organismo
responsable de aprobar los proyectos de
construcción en irán habían expresado
repetidamente su preocupación acerca del
edificio habían presentado estos riesgos
a las autoridades municipales pero la
construcción siguió adelante de todos
modos las protestas estallaron poco
después del colapso en abadán y luego en
otras ciudades de irak
la policía les disparó a los
manifestantes y los golpeó utilizaron
tanto gas lacrimógeno contra ellos que
hubo que suspender las operaciones de
rescate
de
muchos manifestantes fueron detenidos
entre ellos conocidos activistas
creo que todos expresamos la rabia que
hemos acumulado a lo largo de los años
había mucha gente en las calles
el líder supremo de la revolución
islámica el ayatolá jamenéi solicitó que
se procesará a los responsables del
derrumbe las autoridades regionales han
detenido a 13 personas entre ellas el
alcalde de abarán y dos ex alcaldes
muchas gracias a todos nuestros
observadores por enviarnos sus ideas e
imágenes ya saben que pueden escribirle
a nuestro equipo los contactos aparecen
en pantalla para proponer ideas y
enviarnos fotos o vídeos les recuerdo
también que pueden encontrar todos
nuestros artículos en nuestro sitio web
nos vemos en la próxima emisión de los
observadores de france 24